the woke chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff mark milley
is calling former president trump a nazi
who attempted
a coup president trump for his part is
insulting general milley and also
insisting quote
i'm not into coups at the same time
there is potentially consequential
evidence of voter fraud
in georgia just coming out with all of
that going on
is it any wonder that huge swaths of
america
want to succeed i'm michael knowles it's
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday
quote so when joe rogan states his
opinion on the vaccine
it's don't listen to him he's not a
doctor but when a teenage singer in 10
inch heels tells everyone to take the
vaccine
everyone needs to listen to her
immediately and go get vaccinated now
you're getting it
now you understand that's how the
science and the expertise
works if you ally with
some scientists and the liberal blob
that's all good and your word is as good
as the gospel
if you ally with other scientists and
the dissidents the people on the
on the right the conservatives then you
are endangering public health and you
need to be cast into the outer darkness
where there is wailing and gnashing of
teeth do you know where there isn't
wailing and gnashing of teeth
on my helix mattress because it's so
comfy when i'm on the road one thing
that i truly miss
is my helix mattress because helix makes
a mattress designed for you you're a
very special person
okay you don't just need the
one-size-fits-all mattress you want to
know how
exactly how soft what's your weight
what's your size what do you want
well helix knows that everyone's unique
you take a sleep quiz it takes like two
seconds it is very quick to take
they will match a perfect mattress for
you
they will ship it out to you and you
will have a wonderful sleep helix was
awarded
the number one best overall mattress
pick by gq and wired magazine in 2020
you can go to helixsleep.com knowles
seriously the sleep quiz will take two
minutes
and they will match you to a customized
mattress for the best sleep of your life
they've got a 10-year warranty you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
but you're not going to return it so
it's no big deal you can get it look
it feels great you know 10-year warranty
but you truly will not need that helix
is offering up to 200 bucks off all
mattress orders right now
and two free pillows for our listeners
at helixsleep.com
knowles go to helixsleep.com for up to
200
off and two free pillows very serious
allegations
of voter fraud in georgia this coming
from tucker carlson who uncovered what's
going on
here are just the facts we don't know
very much more about this right now but
here's here's what we do know
at least 36 batches of mail-in ballots
from
the election were double counted in
fulton county
where all of us were saying there were
irregularities and the blob told us that
there were no irregularities in fulton
county
and how dare you suggest otherwise and
if you do you're an insurrectionist nazi
coo engaging secessionist or whatever
and
uh you'd be banned from social media if
you said it we said it anyway
it we had to dance around the new rules
because the sensors really didn't want
this
this stuff coming out well now we know
there were at least 36 batches of
mail-ins
that were double counted that's a total
of more than 4 000 votes by the way keep
in mind
biden won in georgia by fewer than 13
000 votes
so this is 4 000 votes really matters
here 4 000 votes
from that from that batch it was double
counted those numbers come from a group
called voter
ga voter georgia which had to sue to
even get
access to the ballots to see what was
going on the final tally from the double
counts that we know about
amounts to more than 3 300 votes for joe
biden
and 865 votes for donald trump even the
atlanta
journal constitution which is
left-leaning uh agrees with this
in theory there's an elections expert
his name is mark davis he analyzed data
from the post office because don't
forget there's
widespread use of mail on votes he found
that 35
000 georgia voters had moved out of
their county of residence
more than a month prior to election day
making them ill ineligible to vote so
according to that election expert
35 000 of those votes not eligible to
remind you
13 000 votes decided the election in
georgia are we
are we allowed to say this are we
allowed to point the set tucker said it
he said it on television
so i'm hoping that gives us but probably
not i think the rules are actually
tighter on social media
than they are in certain areas of tv
but if you suggest those hate facts
if you suggest those dangerous evil
terrible
truths then you will you will be smeared
as a nazi
and a vile bigot insurrectionist which
is what the chairman of the joint chiefs
of staff is doing mark milley
there's a great meme of general milly
going around where he's got
pink megan repino hair and instead of
all of his metals and
and uh ribbons he's just got the rainbow
flag
in blm seem like i don't know why people
think that the army's gone woke listen
up soldier did you just misgender me
so so anyway millie is really really
going far left and according to a new
book
he said on the of the capital riot he
said quote
these guys are nazis they're boogaloo
boys they're proud
boys these are the same people we fought
in world war
ii yeah that's it they got the horn guy
the horn guy dancing on pelosi's desk
the smiley guy with the lectern
they're that they're basically adolf
eichmann right they're
himmler i think is i don't
i don't think so i don't think horn guy
is dr mengele
or gerbils or hitler or anyone else i
think
general milly is just
a hysterical little lib
i don't know how else to put it i know
he's a big tough military guy but he's
really
really pathetic really pathetic as
president trump said president trump you
know he doesn't have twitter now
so he can't tweet but he sends out these
press statements
that just are tweets and but there's no
character limit so sometimes they go on
longer but they are they just are his
tweets
and then journalists will post some of
them on twitter so it's a way for him to
get around the ban
i have to read this one at length this
this statement from president trump just
it pulled on my heartstrings because it
reminded me how much jack dorsey took
from us
how much i missed this man his response
to general milley
despite massive voter fraud and
irregularities in the 2020 presidential
election scam that we are now seeing
play out in very big and important
states i never threatened or spoke to
anyone
a coup of our government so ridiculous
sorry to inform you but an election is
my form of coup
and and that's one of the one of the
great lines and if i was going to do a
coup
one of the last people i would want to
do it with is general mark milley
why is that mr president he got his job
only because the world's most overrated
general
james mattis could not stand him had no
respect for him
and would not recommend him to me so
hold on wait a second you're telling me
that mattis didn't like this guy so
so you appointed him to a position mr
yes he says to me the fact
that mattis didn't like him just like
obama didn't like him and actually fired
me like was a good thing
not a bad thing i often act counter to
people's advice who i don't respect
so now he's taking the opportunity to go
after millie
and his apparent opponent jim mattis at
the same time in any respect i lost
respect for melee
when we walked together to saint john's
church which was still smoldering from a
radical left fire set the day before
side by side a walk that has now been
proven to be totally appropriate that's
true
people said that it was awful and
violent they cleared the place of
peaceful protesters and that just isn't
true even the mainstream media had to
admit that now
and the following day milly choked like
a dog in front of the fake news
when they told him they thought he
should have been walking with the
president which turned out to be
incorrect
he apologized profusely making it a big
story instead of saying i am proud to
walk
with and protect the president of the
united states had he said that it would
have all been over no big deal but i saw
at that moment he had no courage or
skill
certainly not the type of person i would
be talking coo with
so i think it's probably ill-advised for
president trump to keep bringing up this
hypothetical of what he would do
if he were going to perpetrate a coup
d'etat
but it's very funny it's very trumpy and
the points he's making here about
millie's lack of political courage that
is just obviously true
whatever courage millie has had on the
battlefield in the arena of politics the
guy licks his finger puts it in the air
figures out which way the wind blows and
when it blows left he goes with it
then then the greatest line of this
entire
not tweet he's not the type of person i
would be talking coo with
i'm not into coos i'm not into coos
in fact around the same time melee in a
conversation was an advocate of changing
all the names of our military forts and
basis who's going on that he's woke he's
left he's terrible
and he's destroying the country really
good really good tweet from president
trump a really good point i mean it's
funny and it's entertaining and this is
this is something by the way when people
go after president trump for the tweets
you should know that antonin scalia as
as urbane and educated and serious and
american statesmen
as ever we've had in recent memory he he
pursued the same strategy
trump tweets with wild language
and audacious statements and crazy
capitalization
because it gets your attention and then
you read them if he had issued a bland
press statement none of us would be
reading it today including me scalia did
the same thing with his dissents
when he would lose a case and the he
felt it was a really bad decision
he would write a descent that was often
very funny
he would use words like applesauce and
argle borrow he would use statements
when they redefined marriage
and pretended that there's a
constitutional right to intimacy
uh scalia made fun of that and in it he
said uh
marriage uh restricts rather than
expands the right to intimacy
ask the nearest hippie right that that's
a kind of trumpy statement it's one that
catches your attention it catches the
attention of law students so i'm glad
that trump
did that because what's going on in our
federal government right now
is radical it's woke it's insane it's
upending our traditional standards
but people aren't paying too much
attention to it senator cruz
often refers to this as boring but
radical but it's kind of boring it's
just go
just the chairman of the joint chiefs
he's just going to get critical race
theory into into the reading list or the
the chief naval operations or the
heads of the various departments they're
just going to push radical policies
and then no one's going to say boo and
joe biden's so boring that he doesn't
attract a lot of attention
the the dhs secretary right now mayorkas
is issuing a directive to the cubans who
are protesting against the communist
regime
this is mayorkas this is the biden
administration they've actually told
people to surge to the border at various
times
now he's saying to the cubans don't come
allow me
to be clear if you take to the sea
you will not come to the united states
the time is never right to attempt
migration
by sea to those who risk their lives
doing so this risk is not worth taking
again i repeat do not risk your life
attempting
to enter the united states illegally you
will not
come to the united states by the way the
the policy for decades in the united
states with regard to cuban illegal
immigration was called wet foot dry foot
if you've got
one foot onto american soil you were
given asylum
you would not have to be returned to
cuba it's a great great policy
especially because cubans vote for
republicans so that's a really really
love that policy
uh barack obama reversed that because he
was sympathetic toward cuba's communist
government
and now majorcas is doubling down what
what the administration is saying
sometimes explicitly sometimes
implicitly is
hey honduras guatemala el salvador
mexico flood over come over to our
to our country cross the border
illegally in record numbers
oh cubans the one hispanic group that
votes republican
the one hispanic group that is not
statistically very likely to vote for
democrats
yeah don't come don't come you stay
there stay in your communist
oppression the whole situation
just makes you want some relief it's
nauseating to think about what's going
on
and when i'm feeling nauseated i reach
for relief band
there are lots of reasons that people
can feel nauseated some of them
pretty serious chemotherapy for instance
or morning sickness
or migraines i get a lot of migraines
anxiety
some people it's just a plain old
hangover and
whatever the cause of your nausea you
got to try out relief band relief band
is the number one
fda cleared anti-nausea wristband it has
been clinically
proven to work to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent
nausea and vomiting it's a hundred
percent
drug free there are zero side effects
it's
all natural michael it sounds too good
to be true this is technology that was
developed 20 years ago for use in
hospitals now relief band is making that
available to the people
there are there are silly imitators that
you know you try and
obviously won't do anything you need the
real deal you need the one that is fda
cleared and clinically proven to work as
the world opens back up do not let fear
of nausea keep you back
a relief band has an exclusive offer
right now for our listeners if you get a
reliefband.com use promo code knowles
you'll get 20
off plus free shipping and a no
questions asked 30 30-day money-back
guarantee that is
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com
promo code knowles for 20 off plus free
shipping the official policy of the
biden administration
with regard to communist cuba is
the refugees can't come here refugees
from all over latin america
come to the united states refugees from
all over the middle east come to the
united states
refugees from huge swaths of africa come
to the united states refugees from cuba
too bad got to keep living under
communism they actually can't even call
it communism jinsaki
was just asked about what's going on she
squirmed she couldn't utter the word
communism do you think that people are
leaving cuba because they don't like
communism
i think we've been pretty clear that we
think people are leaving cuba or not
leaving cuba or protesting in the
streets all as well because
they are opposed to the oppression to
the mismanagement of the government
in the country and we certainly support
their rights of protests we support
uh their efforts to speak out against
their treatment in cuba
i will say separately an important
question is also
what happens when people are seeking uh
protection or what happens when they are
attempting to flee in the past as i
noted we've had several
humanitarian programs such as family
reunification parole programs for both
haiti and cuba those were policies or
processes that were in place
prior to the trump administration though
if not those have not been turned back
on
as secretary mayorkas said yesterday
that was a lot of words to say yes
one that because the question was do you
think people are fleeing communism
the answer is yes that's what the cubans
are saying it is
that's what serious observers are saying
it is in the united states but the
government
our own government can't say yes she
said i think we've been pretty clear
blah blah blah blah you see and the
thing
and the fact and you know in the butt
and the heat well that's not very clear
not very clear at all
if the if ifs and butts were candy and
nuts we'd all have a merry christmas
because
jen saki's statement contain a lot of
them and she can't call out communism
because
not only is the united states government
broadly sympathetic to the
castro communist regime as barack obama
proved when he tried to normalize
relations without any concessions
whatsoever
and when he downplayed communism in
havana
but also because the american left is
broadly sympathetic to communism that's
that's not
that's not a an overstatement it's not
hyperbolic
now whenever you invoke communism this
is one of the major ideological
developments of the past century and a
half it was
very had played a very significant role
in the politics of the last century
whenever you mention communism you're
told oh that's the red scare oh you're
worried about a phantom oh you're
worried it's just imaginary
communism is one of the most
consequential political movements that
has ever existed
the communist empire in the soviet union
still existed
30 years ago it was still up it was
still moving there's still communist
governments
on earth and the american left has
always been very sympathetic to it
in some cases they openly defended it
in some cases they deceived our own
government and got into
very high positions of power in the
government i'm thinking of alger hiss
i'm thinking of harry dexter white i'm
thinking of many many other communists
in the government
to advocate for communism
and we're not we're not even going to
mention it now
but blm is an explicitly marxist
organization
huge numbers of leftist professors who
are forming the minds of the next
generation of americans
are openly marxists and this is why by
the way so blm that's what's going on in
the streets right now that is the the
terrorist wing of the democratic party
blm is openly defending the cuban regime
blm sent out a statement quote
black i'm now truncated it was a very
very long statement but it wasn't as
funny as trump so i'll just just read
the highlights
black lives matter condemns the u.s
federal government's inhumane treatment
of cubans
pause right there the cubans living in
the united states
seem to be thriving you know they've got
i don't know if you've been to miami
recently they're living their best life
okay they're doing a lot better than the
cubans are doing in cuba
where the cuban government actually is
oppressing them
blm urges the united states to
immediately lift the economic embargo
the people of cuba are being punished by
the us government because the country
has maintained its commitment to
sovereignty
and self-determination u.s leaders have
tried to crush this revolution for
decades right this
the communist regime in cuba which is
now 60 years old is still called the
revolution
this is why the communist leaders like
fidel castro still wear military
fatigues
because they're they're obviously just
the dictatorship the corrupt
the corrupt government there but they
have to pretend that they're still
revolutionaries
because the revolution is always
perpetual on the left now we look to
president biden to end the embargo
something barack obama called for in
2016.
this embargoes a blatant violation of
human rights and it must come to an
end the cuban protesters don't agree
with blm
the cuban protesters wave as their chief
symbol of protest the american flag
they sew it onto their blue jeans they
put american flag stickers onto their
bicycles
i saw it myself that is the protest
symbol
in cuba in the united states
leftists chill for the communist regime
in cuba
and they burn the american flag and they
disrespect the american flag not just
the fringe radicals not just the blm
terrorists in the streets
but professional football players
elected
democrats all the way up they disrespect
the american flag that's the difference
that's the difference is it any wonder
then that huge swaths of the country
want to secede they do we talked about
this yesterday
the civil war because you're getting
you're getting a lot of civil war
rhetoric from joe biden joe biden keeps
invoking the civil war
you're not getting a lot of civil war
rhetoric from republican
leaders or conservative leaders i don't
think
the conservatives and the republicans
are that eager to wage a civil war or
anything like that
but according to a new poll there are a
lot of
republicans especially in the south who
favor secession
and by the way there are a lot of
democrats who favor secession especially
in the pacific northwest
a poll conducted by yougov in
conjunction with brightline watch
asked this question would you support or
oppose your state seceding from the
united states
to join a new union with a list of some
new states in the union and varies
obviously by state
37 percent overall
want to dissolve the union 37 of
americans
period want to dissolve the united
states not a good sign
that republicans and independents in the
south so independents as well not just
republicans
were uh favorable to secession 66
of the republicans in the south 50 of
the independents
but then even of the democrats it's
almost the same number
47 of democrats in pacific states said
that they want to break
off and huge portions of independence in
the heartland and the mountain states
also want to form their own country why
why do they want to do this
because as a matter of culture and
increasingly as a matter of official
policy we are living
in different countries there is a there
is a major disagreement about what the
country is this is one of the aspects
that i cover in my book speechless
in the 1970s when the second wave
feminists came in and they said the
personal
is the political they upended all of the
settled norms and standards
and rituals and traditions of our
culture so everything was up for
political debate this is why now we have
political debates over our running shoes
and our chicken sandwiches
so and what a man is we can't even agree
what a man is or what a woman is so
because we have all of these
debates right now we have radically
different views in order to have a
country you need to have some things in
common and so that can be any number of
things that can be
religion well we increasingly don't have
that it can be race many countries in
the world
have a common race but the united states
does not this was the joke yesterday
when
the economist was shocked that the
italian soccer team was made up of
italians
no one would no one is shocked that the
nigerian soccer team is made up of
nigerians but the italians it's not
allowed to be made up of italians
but in the united states we obviously
don't have a common race it can be a
common language increasingly we don't
even have a common language
right a lot of people notably will speak
spanish
and and will not be encouraged to
assimilate and learn english but even
the people who speak english don't
speak a common language because some
people call bruce jenner bruce jenner
and call him he and some people call
bruce jenner caitlyn jenner and call him
her
and so even the people are speaking
english are not speaking the same
language
and we have different national symbols
the conservatives have the american flag
the stars and stripes
and the leftists have the rainbow flag
and the blm flag and those are the
different symbols of different countries
so it's no wonder that people want us to
see they're seeing
they're seeing this secession happening
before their very eyes the only question
is if one is going to
acknowledge it and the only way that
we're going to survive as a country with
these kinds of troubling numbers
is if is not maximizing everyone's
individual choice to believe whatever
they want to find their own concept of
existence
is to insist upon a unified standard
and get everybody on the same page on
certain fundamental matters at the very
least
who's a man and who's a woman
who is a man who is a woman that is a
question that really
is very troubling these days and the
emojis are not
or not making this any easier emoji is
releasing new you know the little
pictures of people that you put in text
messages so they're releasing new emojis
including a pregnant man
so it's a man with a mustache with a big
belly and he's kind of holding his belly
and i was trying to think is there any
way to see the glass half full here
to find a silver lining in this storm
cloud of sexual confusion and i thought
yes
i finally have an emoji to represent
how i feel after i eat a delicious
hoagie
so i i've never had that emoji before
you know maybe i'd do a smiley face or
a sleepy face but no it's it's a man
rubbing his belly with a smile on his
face that
that is my i now can express myself i'm
i'm pleased
some people are going to be confused
though and believe that it suggests that
a man
can become pregnant when in fact a man
cannot become pregnant
but in our emojis don't forget they're
not just little pictures
they are part of our language they are
how we communicate
and the younger you are the more more
likely you are to be adept
at communicating in this way like like
the ancient egyptians with hieroglyphics
you'll understand more what the meaning
of the emojis is
the various ironies and things like that
so people are making fun of the pregnant
man now
but as language persists this will just
come to be considered normal mark my
words
big tech is going to insist on that
because right now by the way if you
question it if you say you know bruce
jenner is a man or something
you are at grave risk of being booted
from social media from communications
platforms
and and so you won't you will be
silenced you won't be able to
communicate at all
and the biden administration wants to
ramp this up so
joe biden's surge in general right now
is calling on big tech
to impose even greater penalties
on people who post misinformation
about covet 19 and about the vaccine
misinformation they want to slow the
spread of misinformation and they want
to punish information that is false
inaccurate or misleading according to
the best available evidence and there's
the problem
there's the problem about the best
available evidence because if you had
asked me
when the vaccines were first announced
hey should
should young people who are at
statistically very very little risk of
dying of covid
should they take the vaccine i i would
have said
no because the vaccines almost certainly
pose some
risk i mean they do pose a risk because
we didn't really know very much about
them
and i think it could be dangerous to
young people and young people don't face
rape danger from the virus so no they
shouldn't they shouldn't get the vaccine
and unless they're absolutely impelled
to do it but then it's a political
reason it's not a scientific or medical
reason to get the vaccine
and and according to the best available
evidence at that time that was
misinformation
because we were told by all the genius
experts the vaccines are 100
safe there is no risk whatsoever for
anybody
and then what we find out the fda and
the cdc are saying the johnson johnson
vaccine causes
blood clots in some cases in women the
johnson johnson vaccine
we are told by by the actual public
health professionals now
and the agencies is causing uh
rare side effects and a nerve nervous
system side effect
in men and women we're told that the
mrna vaccines are causing myocarditis
in young people where this would be very
rare
to experience otherwise those are so i
would have been right
but because i was telling the truth in
the face of
the genius experts that would have been
called misinformation this is how the
regime operates
the information changes but the
imposition does not and people want you
to get that vaccine
in california now i think we actually
predicted this on this show
i don't remember the exact circumstance
but i do remember talking about this
in the hypothetical in
california now they are so desperate to
get people to take the vaccine that they
are offering them
marijuana the sin spinach the devil's
lettuce joints for jabs in long beach
california
people who are aged 21 and older who get
vaccinated at a pop-up clinic will
receive a token
for redeemable for one pre-rolled joint
quote to encourage equitable
distribution of the covid vaccine
coronavirus is a respiratory infection
it causes people to cough that's it
makes it difficult to breathe
and in very extreme cases you need to be
intubated and so to convince you
to get the vaccine to allegedly protect
your lungs
they are going to give you a drug that
rips up your lungs
that is the logic of our genius public
health professionals
because by the way everyone wants the
vaccine right because by the way kovitz
so
so dain it's so dangerous that no one
wants the vaccine
the vaccine which is so wonderful that
nobody wants that
they've actually got to bribe potheads
with drugs to get it
makes a lot of sense doesn't it speaking
of dubious medical science
up in america's hat our neighbors up
there in canada the toronto police
department
is refusing to confirm
the biological sex of an alleged
child sex offender the daily wire
reached out for comment
to this police department and the police
department said that the information
is quote irrelevant and uh
instead they just discussed this this
sex abuser's uh gender identity
and preferred pronouns the authorities
in canada but
you know it's america's hat it's on its
way here the authorities are now saying
that sex is irrelevant
to a sex crime case it's irrelevant
doesn't matter and it's this guy's
obviously a dude
he goes by ruby eb he's a 33 year old he
has sexually abused others in the past
you can see a picture of him he's
obviously a dude
but the woke pd up in toronto
will not acknowledge that because that
might be offensive to the child molester
and we can't do that but really it would
just be offensive to the liberal regime
which is trying to redefine all of
reality up to and including nature
this is going to cause a political
realignment some rethinking historically
speaking
conservatives are the group that
supports the military
and the police back the blue you know
support our troops right that sort of
thing
those organizations the pds and the
military were some of the last
holdouts against infiltration by the
left which had at that point taken over
virtually every other
institution and now that's broken down
the the blm riots of 2020 the
exploitation of george floyd dying
was in no small part a move to
infiltrate the police departments to
defund to abolish
and really just to infiltrate to
exercise
some uh influence over it so a lot of
police just quit
a lot of conservative police officers
just quit that was the point
the woke army ad that we covered on this
show where we were told that the way to
prepare to fight a war is to have two
lesbian parents that take you to pride
parades with
the woke cia ad where we were told the
way to defeat our enemies is by being
awoke intersectional latinis feminist
whatever you know
those were not accidents the the reason
that those ads are put out there
is to discourage conservatives from
joining and remaining in those
institutions
and to encourage leftists to go into
them and they're working
and they're working so now conservatives
are going to be looking
at some of the enforcement arms of the
dominant liberal regime and they're
probably not going to be quite as
supportive
because if if back the blue means that
you've got to
refuse to acknowledge the sex of a child
molester if if
back the blue me if if support our
troops means that you've got to support
critical race theory being taught in our
military by woke generals who call
conservatives nazis
why then i suppose we can't really do
that anymore i think what we really have
to do is go back in
and retake those institutions and defend
those institutions and
and re re-embrace some old sturdy
standards you know candace does this
sort of thing very well that woman does
not mince words
candace is going to be talking on her
latest episode about cuba communism and
the democratic death cult it's available
right now on demand for daily wire
members
if you have not yet subscribed to get 25
off a new membership
with code canvas at dailywire.com
subscribe and also you can pre-order
ben's book
ben's book is a great book to pre-order
right after you have ordered speechless
controlling words controlling minds
thank you to those who have reviewed it
who
bought the book made it a number one
national bestseller such a great
bestseller
that the new york times decided to snub
it we appreciate that once you order
that book then you got to order the
authoritarian moment by ben
uh for if for no other reason then
because that will be my campaign slogan
in 2028.
go check that out right now we'll be
right back with the mailbag
my favorite time of the week the mailbag
first question from camille
hey michael i recently found out that
men and women both
value sense of humor when looking for a
partner but the way each sex defines
that as different
women define it as someone who can make
them laugh
while men define it as someone who will
laugh at their jokes
i have also heard that men wouldn't want
to date someone funnier than them
now i'm not saying i'm a comedienne but
i humbly will say that i'm quite funny
do you believe the aforementioned
statements and do you think
a woman should tone it down when dating
a man at least early on
there is something to be said about
playing the game when it comes to dating
and not revealing too much
of yourself but what about being
yourself when looking for a long-term
partner
since that is what will create a deep
and real relationship thanks sincerely
funny how like i am you it's a great
name to sign off with camille
this is generally true men generally do
not care if women are funny men
generally value a sense of humor in in
women more christopher hitchens wrote an
infamous essay about this
called why women aren't funny it was in
vanity fair
he said there were three carve outs of
of women who he said generally they're
not funny
but they can be funny if they are his
words not mine
hefty or dikey or jewish or some
combination of those things and and
you people were very offended when he
wrote this but then you'll always say
hey
no some women are funny like ellen
degeneres or like roseanne barr oh or
like sarah
oh okay and so it generally falls into
that category
um however i actually do value funny
women
i do i will say this i know i know it
this is not
particularly conservative or traditional
of me
i really value how funny sweet little
ellie's is she's
she's genuinely funny maybe it's because
we grew up in new york
you know you get certain milieu
sometimes you get
people who are a little bit funnier in
those kind of places she is she's
genuinely funny and she
she will come out with a quip like a
really quick line and i love it and i
actually i
seriously value that but it is generally
speaking
men don't really care about that as much
because they find women beautiful
and women are just not physically
attracted to men in the same way that
men are physically attracted to women
so men men have to be funny in order to
attract women which is uh
one of the reasons that things have
developed that way but but if you're a
funny woman
and you know especially if you fall into
one of the carve outs that christopher
hitchens permitted
then uh you know more power to you i
think it's great from benjamin hey
mr knowles listening to your show i
notice you talk about a lot of negative
and even dark topics such as the decline
of the west
abortion the redefinition of marriage
etc
yet you do it with a smile on your face
what is the source of your optimism kind
of regards my
optimism is not optimism optimism is
just a feeling it's just an emotion
and so i don't rely on that i think it's
just the flip side of pessimism
i have hope which is not just a feeling
it is a fact it is a theological virtue
and my hope is this that my savior lives
and i know how the story ends you hear
from the left
they have this faith and progress
progress and utopia
right the the ark of the moral universe
is long but it bends toward justice
so i don't believe that i don't think
things are getting better and better and
better quite to the contrary i think
things generally are getting worse and
worse and worse but i do think there is
a happy ending
so i think this actually allows you to
be a little bit sunnier
than progressives progressives have
convinced themselves that things are
going to be really good in the long run
but because they've convinced themselves
that they're going to get better the
whole time
then when things get worse they get
extremely angry and they yell and they
scream and that you know
it's like the woman screaming no when
trump won the election because it just
wasn't supposed to happen
according to their worldview whereas for
me i just assume that things are going
to get worse and worse and worse and
worse until the good lord comes to
take us all up and so when things do get
a little better
temporarily i'm pleasantly surprised but
when things continue to get worse
i'm i'm also somewhat pleased because i
was right and because i know that
ultimately
ultimately things turn out very well if
uh if one keeps the faith
which is by the way that is a demand you
know
when one is just morose and depressed
and you know
obviously there's such a thing as
clinical depression and they're you know
that these are just things that one
cannot
you know necessarily overcome with just
a smile on your face
but there is also the social
conditioning of being morose and
negative and
upset and depressed all the time and
that's bad i mean that's a sin you're
actually not permitted to do that you
need
courage you need hope it is a virtue and
so so do it and then things will turn
out just fine
from cambray my friend and i bought a
pig
from the local fair when i went to
transfer the money from my savings
account to my checking account
to pay for the pig my bank would not
allow the transfer to go through because
the memo line pig
could be seen as offensive to some
people like ugly people right to who
who one would call pigs to people to
people on the receiving end of donald
trump's mean tweets
even my bank is holding my money hostage
until i conform to the language they
think is correct
how are we supposed to deal with
companies as they continue
to make their policies more and more
extreme
sincerely they're bacon me angry
i really like this new trend among the
listeners to sign off like in these
advice columns with these very silly
silly names uh yes that that is the way
that that uh language works and the way
politics works is that
our political opponents are much better
at this but everyone tries to manipulate
language
to give them an advantage one hopes you
manipulate language within the bounds of
reality and truth and what the left does
is they manipulate language to invert
reality and invert truth
the lesson to me from this is not that
the bank is doing something wrong and
this is crazy and what's this is cancel
pigs are being canceled uh the lesson
for me is
we need institutional power lesson is
the left has institutional power to
redefine all the words
and to say that some words are off
limits and some words are not
and so we can whine about that but we
actually just need to get institutional
power and we need to wield it and we
need to set the standards ourselves and
the left did the hard work of of
amassing that power and wielding it and
we need to do that too from jessica
hello there swarthy catholic sultan
hello there jessica wow what a what a
saucy
title you've given me it seems like
every generation is weary
of their successors claiming that they
will be the worst generation yet i'm a
young
millennial but definitely feel like gen
z is going to run the country and world
into the ground
i mean have you seen what they find
funny on tick tock and other social
media it's quite concerning
maybe i'm overly cynical but what are
your thoughts on the next generation and
the validity of intergenerational
skepticism sincerely get off my lawn
tell you jessica i
i have a different view i'm really
pleased about the zoomers i think the
zoomers the
generation that comes after the
millennials give me a great deal of hope
i think in many ways they're much more
conservative
than the millennials the millennials are
kind of the obama generation so it's
just that
shallow lame kind of bland liberalism
and so the zoomers have more radical
views at the moment also because they're
just younger and younger people tend to
have
kookier views but i think they see
through a lot of the
lies and platitudes and canards of the
dominant liberal regime and i think
i think actually the zoomers have quite
a lot to teach millennials about about
politics i'm not saying things are
necessarily improving and i think
obviously since the 1960s
we've just been in a free fall as a
matter of culture and politics but but i
do have a glimmer
to risk looking on the bright side i do
i do see a glimmer of hope in the next
generation from peter hey michael i'm a
27 year old survivor of blood cancer
prior to my cancer experience i did not
consider myself to be religious
however throughout my experience
battling the disease i found myself
praying
when i was first diagnosed at 23 i was
politically on the left or so i thought
by default living in a blue state years
later i consider myself a conservative
with a much deeper sense of faith i
truly think that facing my mortality
pushed me in this direction it's made me
think that so many americans
particularly on the left
turn away from god because of their lack
of awareness of their own mortality
do you believe this could be true i feel
like people used to be more aware of
their mortality more familiar with death
which in turn made them more familiar
with god
perhaps there are atheists in the world
who would truly be able to face what
seems like certain death without asking
for god's grace but this was not my
experience
he has speechless is fascinating and
deeply important thank you for all you
do thanks
hey that well thank you very much i'm
glad you enjoyed the book uh yes
the recognition of mortality will make
one
more aware of god not just because you
get scared of the dark
and you want some comfort i don't think
that's how it works at all
i agree with c.s lewis that if you look
for truth you might find comfort in the
end but if you look for comfort you'll
find neither truth nor comfort
only soft soap and wishful thinking to
begin and in the end despair
however most people when they ignore
mortality
are are just ignoring reality i mean
everyone who ignores mortality is just
ignoring reality mortality is a fact
it's a truth and so
when you encounter that truth you
begin to ask other questions about the
nature of truth and the nature of
reality
one of which is how does this world
exist how
is it that all of these contingent
beings
such as myself in this world exist must
there be
some necessary being rather than a
contingent being this would be one
argument for the existence of god
how is it that caused beings such as
myself i did not cause myself to come
into existence
how did how do all of these caused
beings make sense if there's not an
uncaused cause that would be another
argument for the existence of god
how is it the case that if some things
are better than other things
right as we all know that there are that
there is not some ultimate good there is
necessarily
that would be another argument for the
existence of god there are many more
arguments for the existence of god
the god that i think the experience of
mortality will give you there's a famous
line
from dr johnson who says depend upon it
sir when a man is to be hanged in a
fortnight it concentrates his mind
wonderfully
the fact is hanging does concentrate the
mind and the recognition of your own
mortality
or the mortality of others can it's not
that it will scare you into running away
from the hard truth that there is no god
or whatever
it's that it will show you a truth and
the implication of that is
i think that quite clearly that there is
god from peter
hey michael i've heard an argument from
woke christians who claim that
non-binary genders are actually biblical
this seems clearly false because in
genesis god created mankind as male and
female
right but they argue that the
description of god's creation of clear
dualities was only meant to represent
the ends of vast overlapping spectrums
for example we have night and day but
also dawn dusk and twilight and sky and
sea
creatures but also water fowl and
amphibians
that makes sense to me but they claim
this nuance also applies to the duality
of male and female
how do you respond to this thanks well
it's a very clever argument to obscure
the
plain fact of for instance the book of
genesis but then i would fast forward to
the gospel according to saint matthew
when christ explains what marriage is
and when he explains what marriage is he
says
god god created i'm paraphrasing
obviously but god creates marriage such
that a man and a woman will leave their
parents and cleave to one another and
what god has joined let no man
rip asunder he doesn't say
that well for one he doesn't say that
men and men will join together and this
will be identical to marriage right that
this is actually actually marriage
involves
no sexual difference whatsoever he
certainly doesn't say that but
likewise he doesn't say that half men
transpan
whatever will join with a half goat
amphibian whatever you know and then
they'll
no it's he's quite clear he's
reaffirming
what what you see in genesis and so i
think
he doesn't he doesn't mince his words i
don't i think it would be very very
difficult
to you know even if one tried to take
some preposterous
a historical uh you know delusional
reading of
of genesis uh there's also all those
other books of the bible
so i i just don't think that's that's
really very effective
final question jason hey michael i was
raised protestant but entered the roman
catholic church on pentecost of this
year i do not
know many fellow catholics particularly
any young women if you get me
okay my question is how can i meet a
grounded practicing catholic woman in a
world so caught up in sin advice i admit
i'm picky and i have zero interest in
scouting bars in other places for women
and i certainly don't want the
accompanying temptations maybe i should
try attending a traditional latin mass
a tough day for that pal p.s please say
prayer for me and my brother cops we're
doing our best even this tumultuous
moment very respectfully jason
story we didn't get to i'll have to get
to it next week the pope today has made
it
very difficult to go to a latin mass
he's reversed the order of pope benedict
which reauthorized the use of the
traditional latin mass which brought
many many young catholics
including myself back into the church
was a very key factor in those
reversions
and conversions and i guess the pope
didn't like that very much
so you should go attend to latin mass
while you still can there are lots of
cute
cute young women there and you'll find a
good gal so
hurry up i'd go i go well you can hurry
up everybody time's running out i'm
michael knowles it's the michael knowles
show
i will see you monday
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 hey everybody
this is andrew clavin host of the andrew
clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets
started so come on over to the andrew
clavin show and laugh your way through
the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin